bienvenue dans votre feuilleton préféré
ça ça ce n'est rien à côté de ça
bon écoutez je suis très content de
laquelle vous avez fait à cette vidéo je
pensais que j'allais être le seul à
adorer ce délire vous adorez tout ce
quasiment alors je sais pas jusqu'où va
l'histoire mais je crois qu'elle est
très très longue donc je sais pas où
m'arrêter dans l'histoire à la fin de
cette vidéo et où m'arrêter de manière
générale dans cette série de vidéos je
vous dis ça mais il y a pas de
d'aboutissement voilà c'est juste une
info je n'attends rien de votre part
juge le dis du coup c'est inutile allez
l'épisode 3 oh ça pose c'est parti
retrouvons notre petite Bruno
oh la fameuse villa que personne entre
nous ne peut se louer lors de ses
vacances
bonjour gros yeux ah ça m'avait manqué
ça 12 voix en vrai je n'entends pas elle
est ajouté au montage mais je fais
semblant de vive le hosse comme vous
pouvez arriver
le recevoir du tout mec tu peux m'en
bats les couilles mais je
n'ai pas
dépenser 5 € pour une tenue
ou pas
mais j'ai jamais dit oui en fait
flashback maintenant de quand je lui dis
non tu viens de gagner une promenade en
ville demain c'est ciao c'est fou je
dois trouver quelque chose de spécial
voilà confortable élégant parfait pour
Rio combien ça coûte vous me la ferez
pas les développeurs combien ça coûte
ok c'est un peu pervers ce que je fais
mais je vais lui en mettre plein la vue
pour qu'au moment où il essaie de tenter
quelque chose je dise c'est non je vais
jouer avec ton cœur Rodrigo et je m'en
fiche Rodrigo car tu n'es qu'un
personnage fictif
c'est incroyable
il m'emmène à l'observatoire qui a déjà
fait un regard avec quelqu'un à
l'observatoire d'une ville s'il vous
plaît
j'ai un nouveau message
Bruno Kevin [ __ ] mais pourquoi chaque
fois je crois que c'est Bruno c'est
Kévin s'il te plaît j'appellerai sans
répit allez j'ai besoin de toi mais
va-t'en frérot tu m'observes il y a des
jumelles ça dégage à un moment mais
qu'il est lourd j'aurais pas dit mieux
je croyais que tu n'étais pas intéressé
par la promenade qu'est-ce qui t'a fait
changer d'avis c'est bien ce que je dis
j'ai pas changé d'avis en fait tu m'as
forcé ça s'appelle un kidnapping
il peut être un peu lourd je suis
content que tu sois venu attends il
vient de chier sur le mec qui lui a
permis de m'emmener en rencard c'est
incroyable on pourrait continuer la
visite touristique ok ouais on nous
diriger dans un autre endroit plus
certainement pas avant
de voir les options payantes mais d'un
autre côté je veux pas donner ce plaisir
à Rodrigo ah bah curiosité me dit que
[Musique]
le service je te présente la fameuse
favela rossinia oh mais c'est quoi votre
truc c'est d'aller dans les endroits
dangereux c'est ça qui vous fait kiffer
dans la vie vous êtes idiot
[Musique]
des enfants et comme une par ici
oh Rodrigo
n'aime pas les méchants
alors est-ce qu'on appelle la police ou
est-ce que drosio pourrait nous aider
gros audio c'est lui à votre avis ce
qu'il est capable d'aider on appelle la
police comme tout le monde
tranquillement voilà
pas la police très méchant ah ils sont
corrompus je crois que les enfants ont
raison la police pourrait être complice
il vaut mieux appeler de rosiers
j'ai besoin de ton aide j'ai des enfants
avec moi ils sont en danger
ok merci
il a dit de les emmener à la maison tout
de suite et hello Cynthia on t'a ramené
deux gosses ils sont à toi maintenant
est-ce que tu sais quelque chose à
propos de ce type tronio désolé je n'ai
jamais entendu parler
ah bah là ça va finir en prison tout ça
d'accord mais je retournerai dans la
favela mais arrête de faire le mal alpha
il est chiant arrête de vouloir sauver
tout le monde je suis sûr que je peux en
savoir plus sur sa peau et ses enfants
c'est notre meilleur option évidemment
va Rodrigo va dans la favela
je compte sur toi on se voit plus tard
[Musique]
à la favela 45 jours on fait le choix on
est 40% à se débarrasser des forceurs
comme ça oh là là oh là là cet épisode
je l'attendais le rêve mec
Linda tu ne parles pas une seule fois de
renégo dans cet épisode s'il te plaît tu
nous laisses profiter ok les enfants ne
vous éloignez pas trop
mais il vient vraiment de s'éloigner
on dirait un hélicoptère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec la musique là le gars ou saxo il
est en train de s'exciter regardez il
sort de la marine de Bruno
[Musique]
bonjour ses enfants sont à toi non pas
vraiment on les a sauvés de la favela
ils ont qu'on va faire
il s'en bat les couilles des enfants ça
se voit vraiment Bruno je t'aime mais là
vraiment
là c'est trop je peux pas accepter
j'arrive je préfère ne pas y aller tu
acceptes c'est super il essaie de te
donner envie de dépenser des diamants en
disant c'est super et évidemment
j'accepte les Lico sur les deux Bruno
[Musique]
je savais comment capter l'attention des
gens Linda ah ça y est la traduction par
en couille tu n'as pas peur
je suis très très haut pas du tout au
contraire j'adore les sensations fortes
on est arrivé
bienvenue chez moi attention à la maison
de Bruno attention
au-dessus c'est moins bien que Cynthia
pas ouf c'est incroyable
qu'est-ce que tu penses de l'endroit
c'est le paradis on t'a rien demandé de
recevoir on va manger tu la fermes
la taille de la piscine
mec ça n'a aucun sens déjà ils ont
kidnappé des enfants vraiment et ensuite
il les amène dans leur maison de riches
totales
est un paradis Bruno Le Paradis car je
regarde un ange la prochaine phrase
bateau que tu dis c'est une claque tout
de suite diabolique dans ce cas
tu évites de faire des tu fermes tailles
Bruno dans merde mais attendez le choix
est vite fait je suppose que j'ai oublié
mes ailes quelque part
pourquoi tu paniques en proposant ça on
dirait que tu veux m'attacher à un arbre
même séquestrer c'est hyper glauque mec
bien sûr pourquoi pas allez la plage
avec Bruno la plage
[Musique]
qui est Johanna
ok c'est pas grave tout va bien
[Musique]
je réponds je me tais je me tais mec je
dirais rien on n'est pas des balances
[Musique]
c'est étrange donc autant de rire par
ici merci de les avoir invités ils en
avaient besoin ils nous rappellent mon
enfance pas du tout tu as pas de la
jouer populaire là tu as grandi dans les
favelas
mais dommage je l'ai construit en
partant de rien mais dommage
du corps d'enquêter il s'appelle Thor
[Musique]
que tu peux faire la meuf
quoi elle dit ça Bruno
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la suite la suite
cinquième épisode non mais là il nous
mettrons là je suis dedans là
[Musique]
vous jouez je te présente Johanna c'est
son ex-femme manager
un de mes clubs johanna est aussi
chargée de trouver de nouveaux talents
notre carrière s'envole on pécho un mec
qui est trop beau gosse et on est pote
avec une femme fatale mais tout va bien
entendu mais d'abord nous devons voir le
tien tu l'as vu le mien déjà je suis
tombé à l'eau Bruno c'est bon tu
ressasses des souvenirs horribles
[Musique]
ce que tu demanderas est un prix
convient tu vas il paraît que l'argent
n'est pas un problème je reconnais cette
oque
pas de jouer avec moi je veux du contrer
qu'est-ce qui demande qu'est-ce qui
demande ah ça devient bien c'était là
jusque là mais là c'est bien
c'est l'homme de ma Bruno
on ne pouvait pas courir le risque en
parlant de risque tu dois libérer le cas
qu'on a cet esprit sa famille a de bons
contacts il peut causer des problèmes
lors de l'Opéra sillon c'est pas
l'opération qu'est-ce que c'est que tout
ça qu'est-ce qui se passe là wow trop
d'éléments
[Musique]
on devrait l'employer Johanna je pense
qu'elle vaut très cher je pour entendre
vos registres les ta tonalité arrête de
faire la purée c'est la tonalité
registre allez Johanna tu devrais savoir
faire la différence entre une demande et
un ordre
mais nique ta mère Bruno en fait oh non
non j'ai fait une mauvais choix c'est
clairement Rodrigo le mec cool depuis le
début c'est pas du tout Bruno je me suis
fait avoir par sa gueule qui ressemble à
Brad Pitt est-ce que tu es encore
inquiète à cause du titre de l'aéroport
tu lui parles de Kevin tu lui parles pas
de Kevin mais reste tranquille Bruno on
a un petit jardin secret je suppose que
je suis plutôt réservé
ce n'est pas contre toi c'est totalement
contre toi mec tu fais trop le foot
depuis tout à l'heure comme tu parles à
Johanna tu m'as dégoûté
ensemble en rentrant en voiture les
enfants sont fatigués rentre avec eux en
hélico de Rosio [ __ ] c'est lui qui a
le droit à l'hélico je suis deg en vrai
c'est un bon moyen de se débarrasser
d'un mec qui t'empêche de gérer le mec
ou la meuf que tu kiffes tu sais tiens
prends l'hélicoptère va faire un tour oh
bah il part tout de suite
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à m'arrêter là il faut
chier
[Musique]
mec alors
il pourrait rester inconscient à cause
du traumatisme du traumatisme lequel
celui que j'ai causé en le tenant à
distance ou le celui de la favela
il se repose pas mec il se repose pas
Linda il est en train de mourir sur le
canapé c'est pas la même chose
et eux ils voient ça
quelque chose ne va pas
et la maison est en désordre et la
maison est en désordre voilà elle met
elle met ses deux problèmes au même
level c'est terrible tu vas bien tu veux
que je vienne de voir oui et que tu
m'embrasses aussi quoi si si ça m'aidera
beaucoup
c'est terrible hein
[Musique]
c'est le frère de ma meilleure amie
oui oui tu racontes au passé avec tu
changes de sujet toujours être franc il
faut qu'on soit franc on lui raconte
mais on lui dit que c'est bien fini
maintenant et qu'il a rien à craindre
une histoire il y a des années on était
très jeune voilà vous avez vu une
relation
ensemble à l'université
et ensuite que s'est-il passé bon tu as
compris mec tu abuses hein quel forceur
et votre première fois c'était qui a
fait quoi ça va Bruno
disons qu'on est passé à autre chose
séparément
tout savoir je tiens à lui c'est bien on
a été français la meilleure chose merci
de t'être confiée
que l'on préfère et oublier on est juste
sorti avec un mec il fait partie de la
vie
on discute demain
[Musique]
les pas vous interrompre
le jean Gada ah c'est le club de Bruno
je crois je vais aller dans ma chambre
me changer vite fait
allez on met la meilleure j'espère que
cette fois on aura au moins un bisou
parce qu'on n'arrête pas de mettre les
meilleurs tenues et pourtant et pourtant
il se passe rien bordel
on est arrivé au jangada Jane Gada je
sais pas comment il s'appelle il y a
Bruno là-bas je le vois ce bel étalon
J'ai essayé de reprendre mon souffle
tous les regards de l'assistance
en fait excuse-moi je veux que tu te
reproduise
dans le jeu c'est pour cette raison là
on est prêt à tout ok c'est parti on va
chanter sur la scène j'ai dû payer 5
euros la prestation de Linda attention
[Musique]
pas mal j'ai pas été pas mal j'ai été
étincelante Johanna répondre avec humour
quel étrange commentaire quelqu'un dit
un truc bizarre tu lui réponds juste
qu'elle étrange commentaire
[Rires]
[Musique]
ah ok on est de retour ça fait
plaisir
pas
les enfants ont disparu
quoi
[Musique]
non pas la fin de l'épisode non non j'ai
du mal arrêter j'étais à deux doigts
d'enchaîner encore mais là j'ai dû
m'arrêter ça fait 1h20 qu'on joue
j'étais à deux doigts de lancer le
septième j'ai pas vous mentir mais là il
faut arrêter là là c'est trop est-ce
qu'on se fait un troisième épisode giga
long horrible qui marche dix fois moins
que les deux autres mais dans lequel on
finit cette [ __ ] d'histoire j'ai envie
de savoir maintenant les enfants
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont devenir est-ce
qu'un jour il va se passer quelque chose
entre un garçon et Linda dans ce jeu ou
un truc une fille et Linda même je m'en
fous mais qui se passe un truc un petit
contact physique quand même allez je
vous dis à bientôt dites moi ce que vous
en pensez est-ce qu'on finit il faut
finir je pense faut finir oh [ __ ] j'ai
envie de finir maintenant oh vas-y il
faut que j'arrête allez je rentre bisous
[Musique]